هنا بحر الصين الجنوبي من اكبر بحار
العالم تحول المشهد فيه من حركه تجاريه
الى منطقه عسكريه تدور فيها المناورات
العسكريه بين بيكين وواشنطن منذ 2009
المواجهات بين المقاتلات الامريكيه
والصينيه فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي اصبحت
شبهه يوميه واكثر خطوره وتحديدا بعد ان
اسقطت واشنطن المنطاد الصيني في اجوائها
بؤره التوتر المتصاعد هنا بين القطبين
الامريكي والصيني تهدد طرق التجاره
العالميه لان هذه المنطقه تمثل اكثر من
40% من التجاره العالميه
الاتهامات المتبادله بين واشنطن وبيكين
بعسكره بحر الصين الجنوبي تعود اسبابها
الى نزاعات حول الملكيات البحريه في
المنطقه حيث تعتبر الص ين ان ملكيه معظم
بحر الصين الجنوبي تعود اليها فيما ترفض
الولايات المتحده الامر وفقا لاتفاقيه
قانون البحار التي ابرمت عام 1982
ووسط تصاعد الازمه الامريكيه الصينيه
يلتقي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكين نظراء من الهند واليابان
واستراليا الاسبوع المقبل في نيودله
لمناقشه التطورات الامنيه في العالم
محاسن حضاره العربيه